congresswoman Omar has been booted from
the house Foreign Affairs committee but
not before some theatrics from Omar's
far left colleagues by the way where
were these theatrics when Jim Jordan and
Jim Banks weren't allowed on the Jan 6
committee where was this when Marjorie
Taylor Greene and other Republicans were
denied any committee assignments take a
look and remember that as you watch
a condemnation of anti-semitic remarks
this is about targeting women of color
in the in the United States of America
don't tell me because I didn't get a
single a time has expired my life was
threatened thank you the GOP is now
doing what it is best at
weaponizing hate against a black
beautiful Muslim woman's time has
expired not be silenced the gentleman's
time
Omar a general in this time has expired
that our country is failing you today
through this Chambers the gentleman is
no longer recognized
all right forget the hysteria here are
the facts congresswoman Omar was removed
from the Foreign Affairs committee
because of her own terrible Behavior her
Reckless rhetoric is irresponsible
rhetoric anti-semitic rhetoric for
example here's what she tweeted out
about our top Ally Israel Israel has
hypnotized the world may Allah awaken
the people and help them see the evil
doings of Israel Omar also used Jewish
tropes about money pushed conspiracy
theories about Jewish influence over the
U.S government and according to Omar
It's All About the Benjamins baby and
then she also piled around with the
notorious well bigot of Israel that's
Linda sarsour that's pictured right
there and Omar even compared the U.S to
Al Qaeda and suggested that many Terror
groups really aren't that bad and no
different from the U.S army and by the
way he or she is laughing and smirking
while one of her colleagues spoke about
American troops being killed in Iraq and
who can ever forget when she described
911 as a time well some people did
Something 2 977 people died that day our
fellow Americans worst attack on
American soil and people still dying
from its aftermath Omar's conduct is so
reprehensible that our own Democratic
colleagues once introduced a resolution
they condemned her remarks she was also
banned from the country of Israel
rightly so make no mistake people who
openly detest America are allies they
have no place representing us on the
world stage in the Foreign Affairs
committee hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else